here to explain former chief of staff
former north carolina congressman mark
meadows
along with fox news contributor newt
gingrich you know
you said something mr speaker when rush
limbaugh passed away
and you had said it before but i heard
it loudly and clearly
and i i happened to be your mc that
night in georgia with the night you
became speaker i was honored to be there
a night i'll never forget you said you
don't think
republicans could have won in 94 without
rush
and i'm asking this question for a
reason
oh i think that's right i think he
created a national audience
could communicate every single day for
free
and he educated probably 30 or 40
percent of the country
into what was going on i think to
imagine that
period without him uh it makes it vastly
harder
for us to have gotten our messages
across and i think this is important and
mark meadows i would say for years we've
got to become the media
okay conservatives have talk radio they
have an outlet where people can find
different points of view uh a few of us
here on the fox news channel's certainly
not anybody by any stretch
we are conservative i'm outspoken i'm a
member of the press i
also give opinion i'm a talk show host
my question is
is it now time that repo that
conservatives people on the right stop
whining and start creating
their alternative to twitter facebook
instagram
and all these other you know big tech
giants
well it is time the the problem is the
federal government has made it very
difficult to compete
they've created this de facto monopoly
my comments yesterday about making sure
that we break up big
tech is hard for me philosophically but
what we've
essentially allowed these platforms to
to become is they're no longer platforms
they're political operations
and and when you see that we've got to
make sure that we
we not only hold them accountable but
that we allow the free market to compete
and
it's much easier to compete with a
twitter and recreate
something that would compete
head-to-head with twitter
facebook much more difficult and yet
what we see
is them silencing one of our white house
communications uh
professionals that went to work with
elise stefanik and
and they said it's a mistake why are all
the mistakes on the republican side of
the aisle is what i want to know
all right mr speaker do we break up
monopolies or is it a combination of
breaking up monopolies
you know you're a big uh future shock uh
fan years ago i have great i've learned
a lot of lessons from you over the years
uh or is it time to say well okay
while we're pursuing that option let's
create the platforms ourself
and then the american people will choose
where they want to go
look i i think there are two different
questions first of all these are
monopolies of enormous power and you
cannot never in american history
have we allowed economic power and
political power to belong to the same
people
and every time that's tried to happen
we've had a populist rebellion
changed the laws and broken them up so i
would say the easiest solution
is to make them public carriers who are
liable
to lawsuit so for example president
trump could sue them
for the total economic cost of what
they've done to him over the last six
months or
the new york post could sue for
the damages done during the period just
before the election
when they banned the post you would
suddenly find them behaving
like economic entities and not like the
playthings of oligarchs
and that would bring you a balance
second i absolutely believe
that conservatives should create as many
alternative
messaging systems and that really gets
you involved with google
and with the apple cloud operation
more than with facebook or with twitter
you you cannot afford to have google
decide to take people off
or to have apple decide as they did with
one competitor
that they just closed them down now this
is a kind of
use of power which really destroys
any kind of free enterprise system
because it eliminates the free
enterprise
and turns it into the playground of
billionaires
who then use their power in ways that
are impossible in a free society
for us to put up with and sean i think
what you're going to see
one time what you're going to start to
see are actions by attorney generals in
these states
you're going to see actions by governors
which governor desantis has already
started to take some initiatives listen
the american people are not going to
take this
lying down i can tell you i talked to
house members and senators yesterday
in light of the facebook decision
there's real action taking place
but we also as as the speaker is talking
about
we need to make sure that we have those
alternative platforms
encourage conservatives to go there you
know
the president had over 200 million
people following him on the various
platforms
it's an economic engine that's sitting
there waiting to be tapped
all right mark meadows newt gingrich
thank you both for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else